angeblich kann jeder etwas gegen den
klimawandel tun
ich habe deshalb mein konsumverhalten
drastisch geändert mein erklärtes ziel
so wenig co2 zu verursachen wie nur
möglich
ich gebe zu viele umstellungen fallen
mir leicht ich wohne eben in der stadt
das angebot nachhaltiger zu leben ist
gut und vielfältig hier in der
markthalle kaufe ich hauptsächlich mein
obst und gemüse ein
wenn sie nicht so viele regionale sattel
haben und ein winter gibt es ja wieder
anders gewesen
grün-rot der rosenkohl porree sellerie
lager gemüse wie möhren weißkohl rotkohl
chinakohl und fleisch auch so ein klima
thema eigentlich esse ich kaum noch
welches aber wenn ich dann noch lust
habe komme ich hierher
hier gibt es rege landes fleisch und es
ist vor allem die verpackung selber
mitbringen
diesen service gibt es nur in diesem
biosupermarkt denn müll ist ja auch so
ein riesenproblem
es ist ziemlich aufwendig beim
waschmittel kauf beispielsweise nicht
unmengen von plastikmüll zu produzieren
ich fahre extra in ein laden in dem ich
mein waschmittel selber abzapfen kann
ich muss natürlich morgen schon daran
denken hier meine deren verpackung für
ein waschmittel mitzunehmen
das ist im zweifel sogar auch ein
bisschen nervig nicht damit man leeren
verpackungen den ganzen tag durch die
stadt fahren lohnt sich aber ich
produziere einfach viel weniger müll und
das ist meine freundin debbie derby hat
kein auto und fährt ihre kinder durch
die stadt in einem lastenrad
es geht damit erledigen wir unsere
einkäufe und das was so dass fünf
kilometer entfernt ist und wenn wir
jetzt irgendwie in die andere ecke von
berlin wollen dann fahren wir mit den
öffis und wenn wir jetzt ein ausflug in
der stadt auf ein auto zu verzichten ist
möglich ich habe übrigens auch keins der
verkehr allerdings macht mir wirklich zu
schaffen
trotzdem glaube ich dass es etwas bringt
guten gewissens setze ich mich also an
den rechner und will auf den seiten des
umweltbundesamtes meinen persönlichen
co2 wert berechnen
es geht um konsumverhalten wohnen
ernährung und mobilität also bei mir
kaum fleisch ökostrom kein auto viel
fahrrad und dann das enttäuschende
ergebnis acht tonnen co2 trotz meiner
anstrengungen
ich bin immer noch bei 8 tonnen 8 tonnen
das sind gerade mal drei tonnen weniger
als im bundesdurchschnitt
das ist sehr frustrierend und in
wahrheit weiß ich nicht wie ich jetzt
mein leben noch groß optimieren kann
vor allem meine wohnung ist ein grund
für meine enttäuschende co2 bilanz
allein die tatsache dass ich in einem
berliner altbauwohnung verschlechtert
meine co2
ganz dramatisch das haus ist
energietechnisch nicht auf dem neuesten
stand
da kann ich beispielsweise nur wenig tun
wie soll ich da meinen persönlichen co2
wert weiter senken
ich treffe michael bilharz den mann der
den co2 rechner für das umweltbundesamt
mit entwickelt hat
wenn man sozusagen sein leben so
umgestellt hat und ökostrom bezieht
carsharing mache ich fliege aber
kompensieren
und ich merke trotzdem dass das nicht
ausreicht was empfehlen sie mir
persönlich es geht ja nicht darum dass
wir einzelne märtyrer in der
gesellschaft bekommen die dann ihren co2
fußabdruck durch extreme lebensweisen
richtungen drei toren in vier tonnen
schieben sondern es geht darum dass wir
pioniere des wandels haben sie leben in
deutschland mit der entsprechenden
infrastruktur der komplette verkehr ist
fossil das co2 intensiv dementsprechend
haben sie diesen nationalen rucksack
immer im gepäck drin also veränderung
schaffe ich wirklich nur wenn die
politik jetzt auch mal in die hände
gespuckt und wirklich was macht da muss
die politik ran aber die politik muss
von uns auch dahin gesagt werden dass
die politik nicht schneller und
konsequenter gegen den klimawandel
vorgehen finde ich frustrierend ich
erwarte dass sie entscheidungen trifft
und bedingungen schafft die es jedem
möglich macht klimafreundlich zu leben
ich werde jedenfalls weiter machen